the first rescue flights took off from
Cyprus early in the morning just before
noon an advance party landed at an
Airfield north of Khartoum to secure the
Airfield and establish a processing
center for British passport holders
wanting to escape Sudan
since the violence in Sudan broke out
we've been working very hard to ensure
the safety of both our diplomats and
also British Nationals I'm really
pleased that over the weekend we were
able to safely evacuate our diplomats
and their families and we now have an
operation underway to evacuate British
Nationals throughout the day more
flights were readied at Raf akriteri for
the four-hour flight South
a400 and C-130 aircraft are being used
they are designed to land in difficult
environments we are working with partner
countries with various aircraft types
entering airfields down in Sudan
to extract the Personnel we're
deconflicting on the ground and in the
air to make sure we operate safely and
efficiently to get out
there are thought to be around 4 000
British passport holders trapped in
Sudan but the foreign office said around
2000 have registered with them the
British government has been criticized
for not acting fast enough and not
communicating effectively with britons
in Sudan first telling them to stay
indoors until contacted then telling
them to go straight to the Airfield
but roads are still very dangerous to
travel on and some people are struggling
to get hold of fuel
the first flight's bringing people back
arrived in lanaka airport in Cyprus late
in the evening one of the passengers on
board that flight told us about her
experience escaping Sudan with her two
young children she didn't want to be
identified in fear of their safety I've
got a call this morning saying we're
calling from the fcto and we're
evacuating people are you still
interested in being evacuated however
you've got to make your way towards
either at your own risk it was a long
journey there were a lot of checkpoints
and it was really hard but we made it
they have now been processed here at
lanaker airport very quickly it should
be said and have now been taken on buses
across the island to RAF at criteria
where they'll spend the night and then
they can travel on in the morning back
to the UK if they want to there is a
72-hour ceasefire in Sudan at the moment
but the hours are ticking by and it
could break at any moment it is now a
Race Against Time to get people out
Alistair bunker Sky News in Cyprus